charlene thanks so much for being here
thanks for having me yeah of course we
love you we love having you on the show
thank you
thank you uh you realize that was
amusing uh
charlene i just um you're always you
know what i love about you you're very
original you're you're true to yourself
i understand you're you're constantly
interested in learning new things and
you've been taking some classes recently
that i wanted to hear about yeah i was
taking uh sign language classes sign
language and they were teaching me how
to say profound things like why is the
universe beautiful or
who are you you love warm milk from
goats are you a
wolf
or a turtle
why are you you're never going to use
those things i just used it right now oh
that's true you did use it right now
i guess i'm an idiot is it is it hard to
learn uh sign language i mean it's
fascinating to me um i was having a hard
time uh i think i'm sarcastic a lot and
my teacher was saying that sarcasm
doesn't really fly that way that's so
reliant on your face and i was trying to
test them out on her like
nice to meet you
not
[Laughter]
she laughed a little bit i think she
realized i was joking but i realized
like uh like we all have these like
neutral faces and i think i like usually
look sad and people don't know what i'm
saying in sign language so it's just
like i'm good
and no one believes me and
they just go off your facial expression
right because they're neutral and then
there's this guy in class who kind of
looks slightly disgusted all the time so
no one knows what he's thinking or he's
feeling we just assume he feels
disgusted
um you have other interests as well you
uh you've also been learning to
puppeteer is that right yeah i've been
volunteering at this uh at the bob baker
marinette uh theater and um it's such a
strange place i feel like i'm hanging
out with all the cool kids who like
puppeteering at the breaks are all
smoking talking being all cool the
puppeteers are cool guys yeah
yeah i think they're i never in my life
felt like i'm gonna go and i want to
hang with those cool puppeteers
they don't let me puppeteer they let me
pull the curtains and open them and um
it's worth it just to be around those
cool puppeteers
um and we were talking to uh bob he's
like 88 and he's he's the guy that runs
it is 88 yeah
okay
that's getting up there yeah he's a he's
a very nice man a little insane but he
means well and i was telling him oh yeah
could we do some shows there to bring
audiences there because they're trying
to save the theater and he's like what's
in it for you
what do you win for it everybody wants
something and i'm like i don't want
anything he's like bug dust everybody
wants something
he's like what are you gonna do if
there's tap dances i was like i don't
know get some taps dancing board bug
dust we don't got insurance for that
wait wait if he says bug dust what is
that never heard anybody say bug dust i
don't know what it means it's what all
the cool kids say yeah
uh all right uh you know you are um
unlike most people i get to talk to and
i mean that as a compliment you're very
original what kind of kid were you i
think i was a very serious kid i
i i was reflecting back looking at
pictures of my parents and i look so
angry and stoic i brought you a picture
let's see a picture of you as a little
child oh my god
you're
you're you're you're playing with such
happy toys and look at you yeah you're
just so determined and grim
i am yeah i brought a picture of an
update i'm update this is you now oh
[Laughter]
and they paved over your yard